Hammond's I'll just die I'll kill over
and die that'll be great
I'm not here on a sleepy baby Oh boohoo
my nightmares are bad but I'm sleeping
Oh
mm-hmm no no you probably don't care if
I have my light on or off it's this is
curtains can't see no I bet you're still
there oh I'm [ __ ] anyway so bring it
on
turn off the curtains you got to turn
off the curtains for Freddy that's how
that works and that's how logic is oh
okay all right man moaning oh hi you
guys coming in there Luke
okay good job Bonnie go film yourself
right oh that's that's the opposite of
good can you hear me snoring that's
interesting in my house where I don't
think I have any other or others or
sisters that could scream at that [ __ ]
I need to get up right now oh it is oh
hi hello oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god that's terrifying holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it's weird
all right I don't know what it means my
hide there's nowhere to hide here it's a
big empty room where am I gonna go I'm
gonna slide into the bookshelf we're
gonna slip under the couch file myself
away under flubber nocked boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy
Oh bones Oh bones I am oh say can you
see how boned I am in my boy oh boy
ready boy how are you doing Freddy boy
Bonnie might be coming down and Bonnie
might bash open those doors and bash in
my skull with its big body oh wow look
I'm a risk a look oh that's a bad look
right that's that's not a good sound
okay am i dead I'm not dead I'm not dead
I'm not dead I'm not dead that's right
you just scare me but that's okay don't
listen to the noises of the night what
am i doing wait whoa whoa whoa whoa hey
the [ __ ] is that
oh my god I don't know what's happening
but I don't like it it's 5:00 a.m. and
I'm too close to this to be [ __ ] it
man as soon as Freddie goes I'm diving
in that corner and the fat die ready go
go go go Freddy go Freddy go Freddy go
Freddy go go go go [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] someone's at my
window please don't be foxy Oh get that
okay I have a funny feeling oh oh that's
not good that's the opposite of good
with it there's I did I fog it by
getting a twofer no they're off the left
okay foxy no no no foxy no no I didn't
think I actually did that I was so
concentrated Oh chef locust ah good yes
you put me in the shitty toilet oh girl
thank you for that why is this in my
basement
goddammit any turkey balls my poor heart
can't take that [ __ ] you oopsie okay
where am I now oh boy oh boy
this is pypy I love pipe good thing you
got strip loss o pipe because that's my
favorite thing to have when I'm in the
dark basement and fearing for my life no
way no how there's no way in hell that I
would ever look back because if I were
to look back and when there's a door
right in front of me okay I look back
you know that did but I did it
I got this I got this I know what to do
I know what to do
Oh like a butterfly like a butterfly
holy [ __ ] I saw that move man no door oh
we're in no Dorland oh no door no door
hold the door no door we ain't going
nowhere [ __ ] door flash him 12 times
does that even mean I got a flash him I
gave give him the old nip show huh I
can't oh no no you were doing right well
I was correct but I didn't do it right
oh boy I just shocked him he didn't go
bad where'd he go up he's here isn't he
oh hey oh hey hey oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god if I look
away do you just go away
that's my head in your mouth I am dead